as the old saying goes the kitchen is
the heart of the home and today we are
focusing on exactly this what's going on
guys my name is David Thomas I'm a
registered architect here in Western
Australia and today we're on part seven
of this amazing arcade course where we
teach you everything to do with archicad
completely free right here on YouTube
now to help all of us with residential
design it's important that we follow a
set of rules and a set of guidelines
today I'm going to be using Luis
ferocio's graphic guide to residential
design to help you guys understand every
single element if you want a copy of
this book it is an ebook that I've just
printed out you can grab one down in the
description below so last week we
wrapped up with the ground floor making
sure that our wet areas were all well
detailed as well as few bedrooms and our
games room today we're moving upstairs
to the Grand spaces the kitchen living
and dining areas now obviously to be
respectful to Lewis I'm not going to be
showing you what's in Insight is a book
I'm simply going to be using what is
available to him on his Instagram page
free of charge if you want to grab his
ebook just simply go to the description
and grab a copy for yourselves today but
I can show you some great information
here even some amazing kitchen shaped
designs and circulation spaces for
living all little minor things both in
the metric and Imperial so that we are
constantly reminded of good design even
when we are struggling to figure out the
best practice so after that let's dive
back into arcchad and start figuring out
our spaces first of all there's quite a
lot of things happening up here and we
probably want to actually make a master
bedroom or some sort of Master Suite up
here so let's hold the option button
select one of the walls below
and simply just draw one line all the
way through and we can pretend that this
right hand side of our entire Suite is
going to be our Master Suite this L
shape at the top can remain as our
kitchen living and dining now for the
purpose of this I would kind of Envision
that the kitchen would either be
somewhere along this back corner here or
completely concealed behind the stairs
on this side now this is a design option
A Design Choice again not really
focusing on design in this course and
also just about understanding icad as
best as we can so let's start by
incorporating just some basic Furniture
so we'll go to our object tool open up
our object and let's use the dining
Suite again I don't really love the
green we can change the colors to
whatever we like pressing OK let's just
drop a dining room table in for now if
we select one of the pink hotspots on
the outside of the table it's going to
let us adjust the table itself so let's
jump across the Lewis's amazing page on
Instagram and see what he says about
table sizes so here's a great example of
dining table sizes on Instagram that he
dictates how big a table should be let's
say we want an eight person table for
one example he's telling us it needs to
be 244 by
107. let's come back in hit one of these
hot spots 2440 press OK double check his
Dimensions because my memory is terrible
as I'm talking and then tap
107 oh and okay now you can see we have
a beautiful eight person dining table
all of our chairs are pushed out if we
click one of the pink hot spots on the
chairs we can push them in a little bit
to make it appear exactly as we want it
to so now we have a beautiful table
let's duplicate that across like we've
learned before open up our settings and
and type in so far straight away we have
our sofa Lounge Suite available to us as
a favorite in archicad which basically
showcases a full round set now Lewis
dictates living room Rug sizes in this
image for a very particular purpose I've
read through this ebook I use it quite
often now because it is a great reminder
and hence why I'm sharing this resource
with you guys today the 2.7 by 3.7 rug
size you see in this picture is
something that's quite critical to
understand basically you don't really
want more the 2.7 meter Circle between
all of these chairs because you're not
going to be able to hear people
conversing And discussing topics of
conversation very easily so if we were
to plant a 2.7 by 3.7 meter rug
underneath our Lounge Suite back in art
CAD we can do that either in 3D or as a
simple 2D diagrammatic expression for
the purpose of this I don't really want
to go too far so I'm just going to
Simply come across the film tool over
here make sure it's on my right layer as
always change my geometric method to
rectangular I can select one of my
drafting fills so this is going to allow
me to have a lot more options than any
of these which we'll get into later and
then I'm just going to Simply select 25
I'm happy with it being 25 transparent I
don't need it to be 50 75 or anything
else and I don't need any patterns so
solid color 25 fitting my pen color as
the background solid fill but just pick
a gray and then we don't want anything
in the background we want it to be
transparent now we can click once type
in 2 7 type in 3 7 and we'll have our
two seven by three seven rug rotating it
accordingly and moving it underneath our
actual Lounge Suite coming back to this
image from Lewis you'll see that the
chairs and the sofa are sitting about
halfway past the rug which means we have
the freedom to actually extend this out
quite a lot so if we open up our
settings for this table and chair you
can see how much space we have how much
width we've got the way we get around
increasing It Is by actually increasing
the space between each couch so this
couch has about 200 clear maybe we want
400 maybe we want a little bit more
let's type 400 push our chairs out ever
so slightly move Center and we can
probably adjust that 450 and will be
perfectly aligned so now we have this
beautiful space 2.7 by 3.7 meter rug
underneath very easy distances so if you
imagine from the center of this chair to
the center of this sofa it's 2.4 and
from the center over here to 2.1 even
worse case scenario talking across the
table which we really really don't want
to be doing is 3.5 so personally
speaking this is not a good conversation
point the person on the right and the
person on the left would not be able to
manage a conversation without disturbing
a a conversation happening across these
two chairs so just something to be
mindful of if you're picking a space of
this size and this caliber now let's
simply pick up our living room set drag
and drop it down there redo the same
thing with our actual table and now we
can understand that we actually have
quite a lot of space this house is
absolutely huge now yes we could turn
this into a theater room or another
bedroom or do whatever we like or we can
really create a massive kitchen with a
pantry a walk-in scullery all sorts of
bits and pieces completely up to you
guys completely up to the architectural
expression that you're trying to achieve
so first of all you have a number of
different kitchen shapes and styles all
of them have different forms functions
and purposes but you'll notice that all
of them are articulating a triangle
pattern if I take a screenshot of this
and overlay a quick diagram and you'll
see it doesn't matter which actual
kitchen style we pick we're always
working in that triangle manner except
along the long wall obviously because it
can't be done personally I really like a
gallery kitchen or an island kitchen so
we're going to be starting with
something like this we're probably going
to be using an island kitchen combined
with a gallery kitchen to create
something a little bit different a
little bit special so let's start
working on that first of all what you
want to do is create your slab tool you
want to make sure the slab is no longer
on the slab General but on the fixed
Furniture layer you want to change it to
a rectangle and you want to go command T
to open up the settings now you could
redefine an actual slab composition or
you could simply change the actual
building material to Stone or whatever
you like change that from 120 mil to 40
mil which is the average thickness of a
bench top if it's porcelain it's about
12 if it's engineered stoned probably
about 20 and you can have all sorts of
choices while you're here you can
immediately change that to a different
color let's go White marble and press ok
now like I said we have a ton of room
and we want to utilize as much of this
as possible so let's start by using this
back wall here and that's a six and a
half for metal Island bench which is
absolutely huge it does not need to be
that big nobody needs another adventure
that big so first of all what we're
going to do is start typing in 1 500
minus so it offsets that wall 1500 from
where I've drawn an imaginary wall below
and then I want to make it at least in
600 millimeters we go back to Lewis's
page he will tell you generic clearances
around kitchens bench tops and bits and
pieces he will also tell you the average
width of a kitchen island bench now
obviously metric and Imperial don't
convert perfectly across and the codes
and regulations in every country and
every state are different so you have to
be mindful about this graphic guide it
is simply a guide for instance he's
telling us that it's 24 inches deep or
61 centimeters in Australia the typical
kitchen island bench is 600 deep or 650
depending on the edging you have now I'm
talking millimeters 600 millimeters
which is 60 centimeters or 65
centimeters which is 650 millimeters
whereas the island is about 900. so
these measurements and conversions
changeovers aren't exactly perfect but
they're a great starting point and a
great guide for everybody I'm happy with
the benchtop being that far across the
back and then I want to duplicate this
bench top in line with the existing one
what I'll then do is move it I
personally like to move at 1550
millimeters because we have the row and
then I also want to adjust the edge of
this 1550.
now the reason I use 1550 is because
this is an Australian disability
compliant standard it allows two people
to walk through it allows anybody in a
wheelchair to move around quite freely
and if you have the space it's highly
recommended if you don't have the space
bring it back into about 1200 1250 and
you'll be happy as well anything under
that is a little bit tight a little bit
claustrophobic and probably more a
one-person kitchen we then want to grab
one of these edges and extend it out 300
millimeters to create our Island bench
so as you can see our kitchen is
starting to take shape we have our back
bench cross here we have our Island
bench here and we have a ton of space on
the left hand side you might be thinking
what are we going to do with all of this
space well I actually want to create
something magical and something special
at the back here almost like a Chef's
Kitchen first of all what I'm going to
do is simply highlight that kitchen
bench top drag and drop to start
creating a new little zone now this zone
is simply going to be 600 wide and 1550
short off that side and I'm also going
to make it 15.50 short off this side so
now we've created a little Island Middle
so when anybody needs to access this
space they can access it from both sides
if we wanted to close off this side with
some sort of pantry or Cabinetry or even
some storage for cups and plates
displays whatever we could and then we
could only access from one side but for
this I'm going to create this as a Zone
this is going to be my fridge and my
oven Zone which we'll get back to in a
second what we then want to do is
basically create our pantry in the
backspace so if we come to our object
tool open up our object settings type in
linen you'll get your basic linen
Cabinetry now I use Linen cavatry in
this one because it's got a number of
shelves and that's what typical pantries
have as well so it's a great little
object to use for the purpose of this
there's no idea to bought you with this
sort of stuff so I'm simply going to
drag and drop it in and adjust it to
create a little space okay so now what
I've done is quickly imported few little
walls a couple doors and re-adjusted my
shelving what I have is two lc8 shelves
on the rear wall two eye shaped shelves
in the middle so you basically create a
full walk-in Pantry it is a massive you
could last months and months and months
in this Pantry an overkill for a three
bedroom house but again not really a
design tutorial it is just simply
throwing ideas out there and getting
things to work we have our huge kitchen
on this side and what I've actually done
is incorrect there I need that Cabinetry
so the wall is on the back side as I
continue to think about it I do
personally believe that it would be
better to close off that side close off
that side and redefine these spaces as
maybe something a little bit more simple
a little bit more practical so now what
we have ideal shapes Gallery in the back
the full walk around Pantry just like we
had before again complete Overkill way
too big and fridges and phrases here so
what we now need to do is simply drop in
a few items let's copy this table across
let's type in sync and see what we have
available to us we'll search our full
active library and I'll try to not pick
a 4D sync for you guys typically I'd
pick something like this because it's
very common in Australia it is a great
sync but let's go sync general purpose
26 let's use style 14 is phenomenal
let's simply drop in a tap press OK
rotate that to where we want it and
let's say we want to put the sync over
here is one we want another copy over
here in the scullery so let's drop a
secondary sync down here in this gallery
now we want to copy paste that across
once again let's type in oven now like I
said we do want an oven we probably want
something like an oven stack Cabinetry
you can download that from graphisoft
and embed it ideally I'd use the 4D
stack but purpose of this let's download
embed press ok to drop that one in row
rotate it around and let's say we want
two oven Stacks the third we want to be
our fridge I'll simply grab this
stainless side by side double door
fridge and import it into arcad press OK
relocate it to where we need it to be
type in cabinet see what we have
available to us we probably want a tall
standing cabinet so that stack cabinet
will be great drag and drop it in once
again and let's just duplicate it a
couple of times extend that one larger
to leave our slab below if I quickly
come into 3D see that obviously we have
no slab between our floors so first of
all let's jump back to our first floor
press command down right click on our
first floor show wish Trace come to slab
change our slab structure so we want it
to be something a little bit thicker
let's go 300 mil suspended Timber floor
and let's just change that to
some form of Timber Timber Pines fine
make sure it's on the right layer and
Trace around the perimeter as we've done
before so now when we come back into 3D
you'll see that slab has appeared it's
on it's not positioned correctly so drag
it up simply take a quick look at what's
going on our slabs are way too low so we
select our slabs let's lift them up 900
mL
and you can see we've got a kitchen
starting we've got the bench tops sinks
we've got our pantry in the rear our
scullery and we can continue to add
little bits and pieces so we could go
back in add cabinets underneath the
island bench and cabinets across here
and overhead cupboards introduce one or
two or even three more windows in the
background and we would be able to call
this a day and there we are drag dropped
a few more little cabbage a few more
little pantries Slover head cupboards
dropped in three Windows across the back
a little splashback window in the center
as well and we've created most of our
kitchen living dining space obviously we
need to drag in our stairs as well as
well as create our Master ensuite so
what I'll do is I'll create this master
ensuite ahead of time available to you
guys to download through the patreon
link down below patreon you can grab it
through the Discord chat all of these
pln files are available through patreon
and through Discord so if if you want to
grab the Palin with the master suite
completely finished you can grab it
otherwise you'll see the design in the
next tutorial anyway that's all for me
today guys thank you so much for
watching I've always finished my coffee
which means it's time to go enjoy the
weekend if you love this video make sure
you smash that subscribe button down
below if you want to see more of this
arcad course it's available to the
playlist to the side of me but like I
said that is all for me today so I'll
see you next Monday